[Music]
tonight fake news cnn
is totally completely embracing their
role
as an arm of the biden white house and
the new green deal democratic socialists
in ways like we've never seen before for
example yesterday
you have mr potato head stenographer
that's humpty dumpty
he's the guy on the far side of your
screen uh yeah
lobbying softball after softball
question and press secretary
former cnn employee circle back jansaki
in a total sycophantic way just an arm
of the democratic party in their press
office including
this hard-hitting question what does the
press get wrong
covering biden i'll give you the real
answer after this
busy summer ahead infrastructure
election reform
what does the press get wrong when
covering
biden's agenda when you watch the news
when you read the news
what do you think we get wrong well
look i think some of our muscles have
atrophied a little bit over the last few
years
and there isn't a lot of memory or
recent memory or long
longer memory on how long it takes to
get legislation forward
or how messy the process of negotiating
and the process of getting legislation
across the finish line
can be and of course it gets even worse
from there because the interview
wouldn't be complete without a cheap
shot as
always because they are obsessed 24 7
all things hannity and fox news
and humpty was widely rightly mocked for
his embarrassing display
and he calls himself a journalist he
truly believes he's a journalist
which he's not he's a dishonest partisan
hack
and if humpty dumpty even at an ounce of
integrity
he would have asked about oh i'll give
you some questions
how about president sippy cup biden
and sake can answer these like we got
pictures last week
of joe biden as vice president meeting
with hunter biden's foreign partners you
know
the same joe biden that denied we played
it over and over
again three separate times that he's
never one time
ever talked to zero experienced hunter
about his foreign business dealings
uh also you may want to ask joe when you
partnered with the former klansmen
praised him praised segregationist
but when you partnered with the former
klansmen to stop the integration of
public schools and school busing
and you said that you didn't want our
schools to become
racial jungles is that racist joe
um you can ask joe why didn't he lift a
finger
he's represented the state of delaware i
think about 5 000 years
and not one time did he lift a finger to
change the voting laws that are
draconian in delaware
and make them far less restrictive than
the state of georgia where he says it's
jim crow 2.0
what does that mean delaware that has no
early in
in-state uh voting in-person voting has
no drop boxes demands photo id
and i can go on and on here with
reaction fox news contributor mike
huckabee along with outnumbered co-host
former white house press secretary kelly
i don't know kaylee did you ever get a
hard-hitting question like that
uh no of course i didn't from brian
stelter who is a leftist lap dog and not
a serious journalist i think anyone can
discern that from that clip you played
but brian i wish he would have given me
a question like that you know what are
you doing wrong as a press well let me
give you a clue brian maybe asking about
joe biden's dog
from the white house press briefing room
asking about joe biden's cat
asking about what joe biden thinks of
the color scheme on air force one and on
day one
how it felt to walk in the oval we did
not get questions like that
the question i received is is the
president glad that the south lost the
civil war
it was that kind of inane ludicrous
coverage of the trump administration
that stands in such stark contrast
to what the press is doing wrong uh in
joe biden's america
now governor huckabee i'm a talk show
host i'm very upfront about what a talk
show host is i'm a member of the press
uh i do straight news i can produce
thousands of hours i do investigative
reporting
i can produce thousands of hours radio
and tv i give strong opinion
i am an outspoken upfront i say i am a
conservative we do culture we do sports
i'm a talk show i'm like the entire
newspaper
i do it all but they say they're
journalists
big difference
gee i've never known you to be that
opinionated sean you've always been such
an objective individual but
i'll have to listen i'm so opinionated
that i think that your daughter is going
to be the best governor in the history
of arkansas i'm just saying
i know you say at every stink every time
i talk to you here was brian stelter's
question he basically was saying this to
jin saki
jin what flavor of syrup would you like
for us to pour in your pancakes because
honey we just need to make it as sweet
as possible for you
this is the guy that took a picture of
himself not wearing pants when he was
doing one of his hits on television
most people when they get exposed like
that is because
the camera accidentally tilted down he
actually did it on purpose because he
was really proud
of that and if he'd taken a look at that
picture he wouldn't have been that proud
but his ratings are down 53 just since
january uh i mean this is a guy whose uh
career has collapsed i don't think shawn
you got anything to worry about that
brian's slipping up on you don't worry
about it
and especially if he ever takes his
pants off again his career is over okay
okay the visual i can't take it you're
chasing my audience away
the image is going to be seared into the
minds of this audience
but your point is well taken and the
reality is though
three broadcast networks two cable
channels
most major newspapers and and let's be
honest
we're we're in the minority even here at
fox
not everybody at fox agrees with sean
hannity actually a few people that
probably hate sean hannity but don't
have the guts to actually say it
publicly which i wouldn't care if they
did
kaylee mcenany yeah let me first say i'm
going to have nightmares being reminded
multiple times of brian stelter without
pants so thank you for that governor
huckabee
uh but that aside you're exactly right
sean
look the fact that there was an entire
press briefing that went by after
falchi's emails came out
and there was not one question about dr
falchi's explosive emails until
the next briefing when fox news was in
the room this is called investigative
journalism it's called your job
and the press doesn't do it day after
day after day
and it is shameful all right good to see
you both
and i stand by my prediction the best
governor
in arkansas's history will be sarah
huckabee sanders sorry
just saying amen to that i'm a talk show
host
member of the press i can give opinions